would you say are the top secrets now if
it's if lester are in there who's who's
dropped out well liverpool are in there
united are in there city are in there
chelsea are in there
tottenham and leicester in the last few
years i would say arsenal fans are
probably like caught some stat now that
you know i mean because i think i hate
them anyway
it's like they drain me start winning
i want to start praising you again
[Music]
i'm gary neville and i'm going to answer
questions from the sport bible audience
write the following people as players
roy keane michael richards jamie
carragher roy keane
number one jamie carragher number two
and michael richards number three
and why are we putting michael asked
just we can put a joke on the end of it
or we can be serious and just tell the
truth i'm sorry mike
he just felt a little bit deadpan it
needed for me i mean
just answering the audience's questions
you didn't want me to fabricate the
answer would you
which of the sky pundits would you most
want to go on holiday with
that might be my god
my key back in may i need you and i will
do because the other two i tell you
they'd be hard work and holiday if you
could add three players from outside of
the top six to the manchester united
squad who would you choose now can you
tell me who the top six are uh let's
let's explain this let's find out a
leicester in the top six yeah aren't
they we'll say the uh traditional
chopsticks all right so the most famous
club okay i would say vardy
you'd have to over the last four or five
years
just his level of performance
um but i i think leicester in the top
six by the way so i don't i disagree
with the way in which it's been
put together
i think i'd be going for three leicester
players to be honest with you
probably going indeed
vardy
i go sheamus coleman
just over the years i think you've been
brilliant full back at everton um so
you're talking to me yeah if it's now
maybe sheamus coleman vardy and uh
indeed we're talking more sheamus come
on back in the day yeah yeah sheamus
coleman probably four or five years ago
yeah three four years who would you say
are the top secrets now if it's if
leicester are in there who's who's
dropped out
well liverpool are in there
united are in there city are in chelsea
are in there
tottenham and leicester in the last few
years i would say
arsenal fans will probably like caught
some stat now that you know i mean
because i think i hate them anyway
it's like they dream me start winning
i want to start praising you again and
then speaking of varsity fans we've got
a question here what's your opinion now
of the fan channels like arsenal fan tv
and those type of people um
relevant
needed
important in terms of messaging what
you've got is
club media
vanilla scripted
inoffensive
bland
you've then got
sort of what would be broadcast
which is
polished
high spend
an element
of
detail analysis truth and then you've
got fan channel media which is raw
passionate it's not polished
sometimes it's not articulate
but it's passionate it's real and it's
raw and you need all three of those oh
and you've got sport bible where are you
by the way it's somewhere in the middle
i'm sorry broadcaster
could you ever be tempted back into
management the right
i don't know why i was ever tempted into
management
no no never in a million years not going
to happen not even if united states
knocking or
united aren't going to come knocking
spend your time as being a pundit what's
been the best scheme that you've been to
during that time as a pundit or as a
cool commentator special but not in a
special good way
has to be been in the stadium for the
aguero goal
thinking that i was in the best place in
the world as a manchester united fan
that day in that stadium they were gone
they were done
oh my god oh i can't wait for them this
game it's unbelievable they've all gone
you know
all the cameras are here the trophies
here there's no no sunderland there's no
one up there
and then he goes and scores and oh my
god
i've gone from there to like that inside
like a minute and a half
that will never be
surpassed in terms of being a stadium an
experience like that to go there
in terms of it wasn't special but it was
special in terms of a feeling of going
from sort of like you know i've never
seen anything like that i have bayern
munich 99
new camp you i have seen it before but
not on the other end of it it's the last
minute of the game chants and justin
inside the box who would you rather have
kane or ronaldo i've been knocked out
two tournaments wherein aldo's one
scored the winning penalty
and as he's walked up i've never thought
for one second
that he's gonna miss
we're out we're done
he's cold
horrible mindset wants to win everything
horrible in a good way yeah joe i mean
he's brutal
success to him he's just he needed it's
a it's his drug success
being a champion is him
so for me uh because i played with him
um i'd have to say him for my life
because i think he'd always delivering a
big moment both of them i think i would
back um but just cristiano because i
played with him and he's just proven it
over
20 years now which ground do you play
that had the best atmosphere
ibrox
honestly we played them up there in
champions league game and celtic part
was incredible turkey istanbul
galatasaray is probably the most
ferocious ferocious atmosphere that i've
ever seen
um but ibrox is definitely the loudest i
remember before the game
at the point around kickoff just before
and
i don't think i've heard noise like it
and
that's all the great stadiums around
europe and the world it was
it was unbelievable it was absolutely
unbelievable where do you think salford
city will be in 10 years time
i'd like to think the championship and
that would be amazing premier league
will be a
utopia
league one
i think championship is where i'd like
the club to go in the longer term
there's that sort of point where you
think right that's that's
and then you decide what you do from
there but the jump from the championship
to there is like another level how much
have you loved that as a project you can
see your fiance
it's my favorite
it's my favorite you know on saturday um
manchester united are playing newcastle
at three o'clock and seoul for the play
in bradford
and i'm gonna go and watch salford
uh and i know everyone in my family my
wife and my daughters are going to watch
cristiano
it's like you're taking the piss by the
way i've got a football club over here
but i know as soon as i get home i'm
gonna get a rerun of the game from sky
because i'm doing my nether ball and i
want to watch that game as well i'm
going to try and sort of i'm just trying
not to
yeah not have the score so i can watch
both
excluding old trafford which ground had
the best atmosphere you've ever
experienced one in england and one in
europe
hamden park
without doubt when it's 140 thousand 130
seconds i put in front under 36 000
and went to see the scotland england
games electric the atmosphere was
absolutely electric and anfield
and fuel directory i mean you've been
there you know what it's like by the
helm